[Music]
hi everybody
over the last two days you've heard a
lot about how compute engine can help
your company your organization meet your
needs and the needs of your customers
better things like 64 core VMs the first
public cloud with skylake GA support for
sa P Hana and discounts on discounts on
discounts have any of you heard those
and thought what about control how am I
going to take advantage of all this that
compute engine a Google cloud have to
offer without control how am I going to
convince people in my organization that
we have the control we need to take
advantage of these capabilities if so
this is the session for you I'm Erik
vana and I'm a product manager on Google
compute engine and I'm going to share
with you best practices around Identity
and Access Management on compute engine
so an awfully wordy title for a Friday
lunch hour so how do we get from here to
here
we're compute engine and beat query give
us the power we want I am gives us the
control we need that's from Alan cause
who's the executive vice president of
technical services at geotab a leading
telematics company they gather over 300
billion data points annually from a
fleet of over 500,000 devices in there
our customers cars and trucks and they
use bigquery to help their customers
make better decisions around fleet
optimization and fuel economy but like a
lot of organizations they need that
control as a quick show of hands how
many folks went to the IO 211 session
yesterday getting total control of your
cloud resources okay about 15% of you so
you can take a quick 5 or 10-minute nap
during the
our section no more than ten minutes
please Laura go over cloud IEM concepts
just we all have the same baseline next
I'll go into specific pieces of compute
engine and how they work and how it
affects your iam strategy the bulk of
our session will be on implementing
industry standard best practices on
compute engine then we'll wrap up with a
summary and Q&A one other questions
since we had moved the sessions from
1120 to noon honi folks have already
eaten lunch all right
that's about half of you so I've got my
work cut out for to make sure you don't
fall asleep unless you've met five
minute group that went to i/o 2:11 feel
free for the rest of you there's one
extra item on the agenda let's start at
the beginning in this case it's the
beginning of life for Louvre one of the
beagles belongs to an engineer who
brings you compute engine in this photo
he's a few weeks old one of the things
that struck me when I joined the team is
how many people own dogs I didn't think
about this and I don't wanna get into
the dog versus cats debate I know that's
a heated issue for some folks but we
have so many dog owners in the compute
engine and I am teams they can guide us
through this session so we'll start at
the beginning with cloud I am concepts I
am is about who can do what on which
resource here are the different who's
there are four types of identities that
you'll be using in google cloud the
first is a Google account this could be
someone's gmail account could be an
account as part of your G suite domain
these are accounts that belong to human
beings they can call API is they can log
in interactively to the console the
second type of identity is a service
account this is the identity that your
code will be running as on compute
engine so for example if you're using
compute engine and bigquery to do data
analysis you could grant your code or
the instance it runs on a service
account and grant that service account
mission to the bigquery data that you
need it's important to note service
accounts cannot log in interactively to
the console we still have a ways before
the robots take over the third identity
is a G Suite domain this represents
every one in your G suite domain it is a
way of sharing a resource very broadly
for example if you wanted to share a
particular image with everyone in your
organization you could grant a role to
the G suite domain and the fourth and
one will be using most commonly for I M
policies is a Google Group a group can
have any of these for a Google account
service account or G suite domain or
another group inside of it so what
happens now when someone calls an API
let's say they're calling the instances
get method on compute well in some cases
compute engine will asked one to one
with I am compute instances get is the
method compute instance get permission
is what we check for with I am other
times it's one-to-many if you try to
create an instance will check do you
have permission to create the instance
do you have permission to use the
network that you're trying to attach the
instance to definition to use the image
that you specified so sometimes
one-to-one
sometimes one-to-many here's the what
you can give these identities
permissions through I am roles the roles
are just sets of permissions for example
if you want to allow developers in your
organization to create instances and
manage them and delete them you could
grant them the instance admin role and
includes permissions to you start stop
create delete and manage instances you
can grant these roles to an identity
like a group on a resource such as a
project there are three types of iam
roles and the one to use depends on your
organization's needs first a little bit
of history when we started with compute
engine we started with three broad
primitive roles owner editor and viewer
at least gave broad access across
services an editor could create an
instance on compute engine
it could also create a cloud sequel
instance last year at next we announced
that we had I did I am roles to provide
more granular permission today we have
over 70 predefined iam roles you can use
these to grant an employee access to
specific parts of Google Cloud for
example if you wanted to allow your
networking and security team to manage
all the networks you can grant them to
compute network admin role that would
not allow them to spin up instances but
they could do network management create
new network subnets and routes and the
third is we announced yesterday is
custom roles which we have available in
alpha this allows you to use which
permission you want to give someone if
you only want them to call three
particular methods you could create that
role you could create them from scratch
not recommend it the best practice would
be to create them from an existing role
so if you have for example an
entitlement system already on premises
think about how you want that employees
access to map to Google Cloud which
methods you want them to old to call
find the predefined role that most
closely matches that and then add or
remove to get your custom role for
example if you wanted to allow
developers to create instances but not
modify the network parameter by
assigning an external IP address you
could remove that permission and the
final concept around I am is that of
resource hierarchy I am is about who
could do what on which resource here are
the resources at the top it's your
organization node which is tied to your
domain and below that you can create a
folder for each division or for each
team and within those folders you could
create folders for products or a project
for a particular service and then within
that specific resources like instances
or subnets or service accounts the
project provides the isolation between
different teams and different services
in your organization so think of putting
each individual micro service down at
the bottom of this resource
hierarchy we'll talk about that more a
little bit later okay so there's the
summary of I am concepts now we're off
and running this is Lou for again he's a
little bit older a little bit wiser
knows a little bit about cloud I am at
this point now we'll go into compute
engine and a few specific ways that it
works and how it affects your iam
strategy first if you're thinking about
security you're thinking about what are
the bad outcomes that are possible
not necessarily fun to think about but
important to think about and whenever
you have a machine whether it's a
machine on premises the virtual machine
or in the cloud what would happen if
someone unauthorized gained access to it
so one to provide mechanisms such that
you can limit what an instance can
access as a way of reducing risk now the
first such mechanism are ooofff access
scopes this was in the pre I am world
where we had these three primitive roles
owner editor and viewer and each project
had one service account that all
instances ran as well if you have this
one account that has rather broad
privilege you want some way to be able
to limit your particular instance or
instance group to just what you need and
access scopes were a way to do that
they're relatively broad in their
granularity for example you could give
some one person to just the compute API
or the read-only methods in the compute
API there's one special scope the cloud
platform scope which allowed access to
all through a cloud api's we'll talk
about that one more a little bit later
now with I am you can use I am roles as
the mechanism to limit what your
instance can access through an API we
have over 70 such roles offers a lot
more flexibility and granularity than
scopes and instances today can each run
as their own service account so each
component of your app could have its own
identity and its own level of access for
the resources in your project or
your organization and these roles as we
saw earlier can be much more
fine-grained than these broader access
scopes one of the common operations when
someone's create an instance you want to
go in and see what do you have a view
you're going in to set something up for
the first time or to troubleshoot an
issue we want to make that easy in
compute engine so if you go to our web
console and you click the SSH button
magic happens Andy you are so what do we
actually do and what's the impact on I
am when you click on this SSH button we
generate a new key pair and we'll send
the public key in to the guests using
our metadata service that's a key value
pair data store then we use the
corresponding private key to start your
session the reason why I bring this up
is that Identity and Access Management
is not just about I am roles it's think
about what are all of the identities
including SSH keys and what can they
access in the guest so there are two
options there first is automatic key
management if people in your
organization will only need to SSH using
either the Google web console or using
the g-cloud command line tool you don't
have to do anything will create the key
pairs if necessary will create a new one
if they've expired
SSH just works on the other hand a lot
of you have existing SSH key management
on-premises so if you want to continue
to manually manage those SSH key is you
could do that by setting them on the SSH
keys metadata field and that will put
the public keys into your instances if
you want to allow all of your developers
to SSH into all the VMs in your project
you can set the public key once on the
project metadata and it gets inherited
by all instances on the other hand if
you want to allow a contractor or a
vendor access to a specific instance to
troubleshoot an issue you could put
their public key on the instance
metadata so there's two levels there's a
resource hierarchy there as well
I should note that SSH is a particularly
powerful permission to give someone
first anyone who can SSH in by default
is also part of the sudras group but
secondly they can also run commands as
that instances service account so
there's a way for someone to get access
to resources that you mean now to give
them directly and I'll show you what we
did about that we treat a service
account both as an identity and as a
resource it's an identity in the sense
that if your code needs to call bigquery
you could grant an I am role to your
instances service account to access
bigquery it's a resource in the sense
that you can grant users or groups
permission to act as that service
account we wanted this to be an explicit
decision that you make we don't want
there to be any elevation of privilege
want it to be an explicit choice so
here's what this could look like
suppose we had a project where a user is
an instance admin they can create delete
instances this is the sign for creating
deleting instances by the way and then
you give the service account access to
bigquery so it can run queries create
saved queries write new data if we
didn't treat the service account as a
resource here's what could happen you
can have the user trying to get a data
set from bigquery bigquery would check
with cloud I am I am which check against
the I am policy it would actually check
against all policies in the hierarchy I
am would rightly say no and bigquery
would rightly say no so far so good now
suppose that this instance admin creates
an instance and compute engine checks
with I am oh you have permission to
create instances yeah first to create
disks here's your instance running as a
service account and now that user could
SSH in and use the service accounts
credential to access that data and
bigquery that we didn't want them to
have access to that's not what we want
instead want it to be an explicit choice
so if someone does not have permission
to act as that service account which
you've given them then this would happen
make query again we'll say no as it
should but when they ask computers to
create an instance that runs as that
service account we will also check do
you have permission to act as the
service account I am will say no will
say now no elevation of privilege we
wanted to avoid surprises
I want that if you want someone to act
as another identity it's an explicit
choice that you make the service account
actor role is the predefined role that
grants this act as permission a compute
engine checks for this permission in two
cases first is if the API would cause
different code to run inside the guest
for example if you're setting a startup
script or a shutdown script we will
check you have permission not only to
set that metadata but you have
permission to act as that service
account and similarly if you're going to
change the service account that the
instance runs as do you have permission
to act as that new service account all
right that's the background we've
covered the IAM concepts a little bit
about compute engine now on to identity
best practices identity here embodied by
Milo who is a Chihuahua rat terrier mix
or a spider at Google scale depending on
who you believe the first best practice
is to reuse your existing identities how
many of you have an on-premises LDAP
server right now ok that's about 3/4 of
you if you have an on-premises LDAP
server like Active Directory you can
install the Google cloud directory sync
tool a free download to sync one way
users and groups from your LDAP server
into G suite so you can continue
managing users and groups well you
always have been and now be able to
grant them permission to cloud resources
the second best practice around identity
is to not store keys or secrets in your
code
you've probably heard news stories about
people scanning github looking for API
keys or heard about the truffle hog
project to help you find them we want to
make it easy to make sure that you don't
have to manage keys or access tokens in
most cases if your code is running on
compute engine and you need to call
another Google API like bigquery just
install the client library for the
language that you need Python client
library for example and things just work
you don't have to get an access token
you don't have to create a key pair for
the service account you just call the
API and it works if you're doing local
development you can download the same
client library to your laptop you can
create a new key pair for that service
account and then set the Google
application credentials environment
variable to the path to that key you
don't have to put it into your code and
then the calls just work we want it to
be easy that you can not have to manage
tokens and keys the next thing that'd be
best practice because again identity is
more than just about I am roles is
requiring more secure authentication you
have heard the identity as a service
talking in there a lot of folks
mentioned how they were already using
two-factor off which is awesome we also
announced security keys a more phishing
resistant token that you can use to
identify a particular user and you can
enable this on your G suite domain just
by going into the admin console and
clicking the radio button the second set
of identities to think about the inner
people who can SSH into your instances
first recommend disabling password
authentication because he Paras are more
secure way and secondly disable root
logins so if someone has to run an
elevated command you have a better
chance at finding that in off log
afterwards
cute engine images already view these
there are a lot of other best practices
around image management that I couldn't
do justice to you here so there's a doc
for more information
that brings us to least privilege decoe
is a bull mastiff and boxer who embodies
least privilege good luck getting
through there's two chairs and there's
dqo in the middle so the first best
practice around this on compute engine
is obviously granting predefined or
custom roles usually depending on how
you set up your resource hierarchy there
may be times you could give someone like
your networking team the owner role on a
project that only has networking
resources we'll talk about that more in
a few minutes there are some operations
that are particularly powerful that you
want to be aware of the first is setting
an IM policy someone who can set an IM
policy could grant themselves or someone
else any role on that resource so by
default the owner and the organization
admins are the two roles that have that
permission the second powerful operation
is acting as a service account as we
talked about a bit earlier because if
you can act as a service account you can
now get access to data that that service
account has access to you can do things
like set metadata to modify start up and
shut down scripts and there are three
roles that have that owner editor and
service account actor the best practice
on compute is then that you give the
service account actor role that
permission to act as a service account
you grant that on a particular service
account rather than on the project you
should grant it on the project the group
that you gave access to can now access
all of the service accounts in your
project including those that we have
nothing to do with there's one exception
if you want someone to be able to set
project level metadata if you want some
table to set a common startup script for
all instances in your project
give them the serfs contact role on the
project and the reason for that
is that if you set project metadata we
don't want to just check do you have
permission to all the existing instances
although that startup script will affect
all existing instance says it'll also
affect all instance you create in the
future and that's why we want to check
for that permission at the project level
and not just on each individual instance
anytime we talk about best practices are
on I am we're sort of duty-bound to
mention use groups not users I won't
belabor this point I will say one thing
if you're managing groups in G suite not
on your on-premises server then that's
in the admin console admin Google com
separate from the IAM policies will be
setting in the cloud console it's all
gonna say about groups so talk a little
bit about lease privilege to users also
least privilege is necessary for
applications suppose that you have a
content streaming company and you wanted
both stream content and also do some
data analytics maybe understand which
next piece of content to recommend what
you add to serve up how to increase
conversion the best practice here is
that you give each instance or group of
instances their own service account in
this case the content streaming
instances have one identity of the
content stream or service account and
this is using for data analysis have a
data analyzer service account then you
could grant you to those service
accounts just the iam roles on just the
resources that they each need to do
their jobs but then give each of these
instances a very permissive scope when
we talked about scopes and iam roles
earlier it seems a little odd that we
would say in a least privileged section
of a session grant very permissive
scopes here's why that's gonna be okay
when your instance is making an API acts
the NEPA request there are two
mechanisms of authorization that has to
pass so in this VM is querying bigquery
we automatically because you're running
inside of compute engine we
automatically
the access token that access token
includes both the identity of the
service account as well as a set of
access scopes what bigquery will then do
is first check is this set of scopes
something allows this API to be called
and if so then go and ask cloud I am do
you have does this service account have
access to this resource because you have
cloud I am as the definitive
authorization store for a Google cloud
platform you can leave the scopes wide
open that makes it easier to configure
your instances but doesn't leave you in
any more of a risk in-state because even
if someone has wide open scopes I am is
still the definitive answer as to where
they can access a resource I'd also be
remiss if I didn't mention key rotation
there are two sets of keys that you'd be
interested in here one is keys for the
service account for example if you're
querying a service outside of Google
Cloud need to export your own service
account keys you can do key rotation by
creating the new key with the create API
replace the old one with a new one and
delete the old one public key is for SSH
are treating a little differently in
that instance metadata is written in a
read-modify-write two paradigm so add
the new key set the metadata do the key
replacement and then remove the key by
setting metadata again
for similar reasons that you don't want
to store secrets or keys in code so - in
instance metadata the purpose of the
metadata services to provide
configuration information between the
Google Cloud BP is and your instances so
things like startup scripts shutdown
scripts public SSH keys instance
metadata is treated as part of the
instance resource so anyone who can get
an instance oil to see all the metadata
on that instance so if for example your
instance use a private token to access a
service that you're managing yourself
store that token or that password of
that key in cloud storage and then give
access to the instances service account
to read the information that way anyone
who lists the instance won't see it but
your instance will still have access to
it that brings us to third section
centralized control embodied here by
Kiera
akley Kai who has a centralized control
of this couch and also part of the
fireplace the first best practice around
centralized control is to bring your
organization's existing structure to the
cloud if you have for example a lot of
developers who are allowed to create
cloud projects what happens if one of
those developers leaves the company and
those resources are still going with the
organization node anyone who creates a
project if their email address is part
of your domain that's automatically part
of the organization node and therefore
your organization admins can set
policies to allow a particular group of
individuals to gain access to them in
case for example the project owner
leaves you could also then take
advantage of organization policies that
my colleagues Ray and Ray discussed
yesterday in i/o - 11 to set the ground
rules for what people are allowed to do
within your organization even if they
have relative autonomy within their
project the
prax is here our first use the org node
for centralized control map your
company's domain to your organization
node and then create folders for
divisions or teams projects for each
service for each environment so you have
one project for a team's dev environment
test environment and prod environment
that way you can give stricter control
over that prod environment while
allowing developers more freedom in
Devon in test a lot of organizations
have standardized IT blessed' images and
want to make it easy for you to share
those images with people in your
organization so it's easy for them to
create the instance that you want them
to the best practices here are first
start with Google provided images as
your base we make optimizations in these
images to run them on compute engine and
include already a lot of the best
practices around image management some
of which I alluded to earlier the second
best practice is to publish your
approved images to a shared project to
make those available to the developers
that need it I'll show you an example in
a moment and the third best practice to
be mindful of is when you're testing
these images before they have been
approved do that test again a separate
project not in the shared images project
you don't want someone getting a sneak
peek at the next round of images before
it's ready so here's what this could
look like suppose you want to give your
data scientists permission to create
update and delete instances you want
them to use your Blessed images the ones
created by your IT staff so you can
first create a data analysis project
give the data scientist group the
instance admin role in that project now
they can create delete instances and
then have a separate shared images
project where your IT staff has the
instance admin roles they can create
instances delete them create images and
delete them and then give the image user
role to the data scientist group so now
as your IT staff publishes approved
images the data scientists just
access to them they don't need to create
their own copy of them they don't have
to download them into their own project
no sudden you have this proliferation
they can just use them directly from the
shared images project so relief for
controlling networks a lot of
organizations have a security team that
wants to have control over all network
traffic you want to make sure that
you're routing traffic through
particular set of firewall rules or
proxies so we make that easy in two ways
one if you're already a compute engine
customer before we announced cross
project networking during the VPC
session here you may have a number of
different projects that already have
networks or something that's in them you
could give developers the instance admin
role on that project so they can't
monkey around with the firewalls and
networking and give your networking
security team the network admin and
security admin roles on those projects
if you're starting something new you
have an even more flexible option
available with cross project networking
and the recommendation there is that you
create one EXPN hosts per network that
you're sharing I think grant the
networking team the owner role on that
project this is one of those exceptions
we don't have to grant them a very
narrow role because that project is only
for networking resources and then the
networking team can grant access to
other groups on specific subnets this
means that the data scientists can have
easy communication between all of their
instances while still maintaining
isolation from other services and other
teams so your policies might look like
this in this case we granted the network
user role to the data scientist just on
a specific subject
in the last best practice this is like
the opposite of camping you very much
want to leave a trace and even during
this conference we got a reminder as to
why when Columbia Sportswear according
to The Seattle Times sued a former
employee who allegedly on their last day
of work had created a new user account
granted broad access to that user
account and then used it after they left
the company to access internal
information the best practices in this
case on compute and some of these apply
to Google cloud more broadly
first is retain audit logs in accordance
with your business's risks and
mitigation strategies the length of time
that you would maintain these logs
depends on what risks you're trying to
protect against and also how many
resources you have to go look into all
this data afterwards in Google cloud you
can set up logs to be exported to cloud
storage or to bigquery for easier data
analysis you can also have them set up
to be sent via pub subs you can respond
in near real-time if something
suspicious happens like someone's
setting an iam policy that you don't
like there are other organizations that
need to also manage and monitor what
happens inside the guests for example if
you need to monitor the sshd logs to see
who's trying to access your instances
you can set up the stack driver logging
agent to forward those events from all
of your instances to a central place and
then you can look for trends in who's
trying to get into your instances there
all right now it's the demo section
before we switch over the demo unlike
most sections is embodied by two of our
teams dogs not one first is copy copies
a poodle very playful we're gonna go
play around now in compute engine that
is a relatively optimistic view of the
demo and noodles embodies another view
depending on how the demo goes also a
chihuahua terrier makes
all right can we switch over to the demo
please okay
so we're looking at here is an
organization they created and we have a
few different departments we have data
science engineering and shared resources
these are all folders in the resource
hierarchy and we have here the data
science dev project we can examine the
IAM policy there well you'll see is that
we've granted the compute instance admin
role to the data scientist group so
they'll be able to create manage
instances here we also want those same
data scientists to have access to the
shared images so if you look at the
images project you'll see that we've
granted the compute image user role to
that same group and additionally because
we want to maintain more control over
our networking and our firewall rules we
give them access to a shared network in
the EXPN dev project and here they are
that same group finally because their
data scientists and data is one of their
favorite four letter words we're also
granting them the bigquery data viewer
role and the big for a user role on our
org data project so they can access all
this data
I'll show you one other resource as we
talked about controlling permissions to
api's that your instances are calling
let's look at the data science dev
project and we'll check the service
accounts there there are two service
accounts one that compute engine creates
by default and then I create this data
analyzer service account and this as
well you can set permissions on
you can see that data scientists have
you surf scum actual just on that
service account not on any other in that
project this now allows them to create
instances that run as this service
account to query that bigquery data okay
now I'm gonna log in as one of the data
scientists
it's very secretive company so her last
name is redacted all right now we are
looking at this from Alice's point of
view who's a member of the data
scientist group so she has access to the
data science dev project she could
create instances there let's see if she
just tried to snoop around a bit so you
can see that in this case Alice and no
data scientist has access to view the I
um policies for this project but they do
have access to some of the other
resources like compute engine so let's
go and create an instance I'll put it
here in US central so the first thing is
which image are we going to use there
are the Google provided images there's a
variety of OSS there including windows
as well we're going to go over to custom
images and we can choose to look at
custom images in these projects there's
none in data science Deb but if you look
at the images project there we have our
custom font 2v2 image that's the latest
one that's been approved so we'll use
that one now we have our choice of
service accounts we'll choose the data
analyzer service account and note that
when you choose one other than the
default
we set the cloud platform scope for you
automatically which means you just need
to think about the IAM roles and not
about access scopes to make sure that
the instance in your code has access to
the api's you need and for the last
piece we will use a shared network you
see we have the EXPN dev network that's
you shared subnets for
and we can connect to that so now we'll
create our instance using shared image
shared subnet and using only the service
account that Alice and the other data
scientists have access to
all right so now let's SSH in there and
you'll see well we're gonna transfer the
SSH key this is generating a new key
pair sending the public key into the
instance and then using the private key
to set up the session
all right now just to show you how easy
it is if you're using the client
libraries to access the data that you
need in Google cloud from within a
virtual machine we're going to install
the client library for bigquery
okay
okay so here's the quick python script
the import the client library
instantiate the client and we just call
in this case the list data sets method
and we'll also list all the tables
within each data set important to note
what's not in here is specifying a
credential downloading a key occurring
for an access token and there are the
logs from the org data project the one
that this service account has been
granted access to and the different
tables in those logs these are all audit
logs from today so now that we switch
over I'll go to bigquery note by the way
that when I switched over to the org
data project because we started in the
compute engine view the console shows
the same view in the new project and
Alice rightly does not have access to
view instances or do any instance level
operations in this project now let's go
over to bigquery
okay and now I'm just gonna show what
some of the activity that happened in
this project today you can see we're
looking at this by the newest first and
so a bunch of the operation that we've
been doing throughout the demo you can
see here Alice is the one who's been
running them and then here are the
different methods that have been called
creating instances setting may the data
to set those public keys all right can
we switch back to the slides please
turns out we didn't need noodles after
all nothing crashed so in summary we
started with the IEM concepts review for
some of you new for others and then talk
about how specific parts of compute
engine work and how it effects your iam
strategy the relationship between scopes
and iam roles SSH keys and the metadata
server and the service account actor and
why it's important that's an explicit
decision and not something you want to
be surprised by then I shared best
practices these three areas around
identity least privilege and centralized
control does these warr the best prices
around identity and how to implement
those on compute engine some of these
are general for Google Cloud overall
such as syncing your identities
similarly the best practices that I
showed for least privilege you should
have a picture of dqo on here too but
there's no space that dog is huge
there's a lot of best practices and then
best practices around centralized
control in a particular around using the
organization note and resource hierarchy
here are some of the capabilities that I
talked about in links to read more about
each of those things like I am roles
service accounts Google cloud directory
sync just in weeks they see they're
still cameras up
and then additional resources we have an
extensive document on best practices for
enterprise organizations as well as on
best practice around image management
and securing your images there are three
other sessions at next this year that
are related to this area all of them
have already happened but you can find
them on YouTube they're already on
YouTube one of those is VP 203 identity
as a service IO 211 gaining full control
and then virtual private clouds IO 401
and with that hopefully we can all rest
as easily as Milo here because we know
the best practices for securing your
workloads on compute engine and Google
Cloud
[Music]
[Music]